دعا لكريمنا الى تسويه التوتر بين صربيا
وكوسوفو بالوسائل الدبلوماسيه وذلك بعد
الهجمات التي استهدفت الشرطه شمال كسوفو
وقال المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه ديميتر
بسكوف للصحفيين بان مسقط وايدو قيام
الاطراف بجهود سلميه من اجل تسويه الوضع
بالوسائل الدبلوماسيه وطالب بسكوف بضمان
جميع حقوق الصرب مؤكدا ان روسيا من اشد
المؤيدين اللي بالجراج نظرا للروابط
التاريخيه والدينيه المتجدده بحسب تعبيرها
انجحتها اعربت خارجيه الفرنسيه عن قلقها
البالغ ازاء الوضع في شمال
الهجوم على بعثته في كسوفه وحتى في بيان
لها طرفين على التحلي باكبر قدر ممكن من
ضبط النفس والتصرف بمسؤوليه من اجل تخفيف
التوراه كما اكدت خارجيه الفرنسيه دعم
باريس الكامل اللي وساطه الاوروبيه التي
من شانها جعل التقدم نحو اتفاقا شاملا
وملزم قانونيا بين صربيا وكوسوفو امرا
ممكنا
كما طلب الناتو بمحاسبه الضلعين في الهجوم
على البعثه الاوروبيه في كسوفه هذه
المواقف فجاءت بعد تصاعد التوتر الشمالي
كوسوفو بين الاقليه الصربيه والسلطات عقب
تبادل باطلاق النار مع شرطه الاقليم بعد
اعتقال شرطي صربيا سابق وقالت بعثت
والاتحاد الاوروبي في كوسوفو ان قنبله
صوتيه القيت على احدى مركباتها المدرعه في
المنطقه مساء السبت دون وقوع اصابته
واغلقت شاحنه ومركبات نقل ثقيله اخرى عدت
طرق رئيسيه في الشمال كوسوفو تؤدي الى
معبرين حدوديين مع صربيا اليوم الثالث ما
ادى لاغلاقهما امام الحركه المروريه